on vincent berger avocat au barreau de
paris ancien expert auprès du conseil de
l'europe et anciens juristes consultants
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme vincent berger bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
117 médecin qui alerte qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de leur démarche est ce
qu'elle peut avoir un impact
alors j'imagine que cette démarche aura
un certain poids aux yeux du tribunal
il faudra d'abord s'assurer est-ce que
assange pourra participer à son procès
en personne ce qu'il aura la santé
suffisante pour suivre toutes les
audiences qui devrait se dérouler
pendant plusieurs semaines lors d'une
précédente audience tout le monde s'est
accordé à dire qu' il était dans un état
extrêmement précaire on parle de torture
psychologique d'ailleurs alors c'est moi
je ne suis pas médecin mais je pense
qu'ils souffrent énormément de de sa
détention dans une prison de haute
sécurité avec un régime carcéral
extrêmement sévère et après des années
de réclusion dans l'ambassade de
l'équateur à londres je crois que tout
ça finit par beaucoup altéré son état de
santé notamment psychique
comment la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme peut se saisir finalement de
scat julian assange alors la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme ne
peuvent jamais se saisir elle-même elle
ne peut être saisi que par un individu
ou par un gouvernement et à ma
connaissance aucun avocat en pour
l'instant n'a au nom de julian assange
saisi la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme mais rien n'interdit de penser
que si les choses tournent mal pour
assange c'est à dire que après ces
semaines de procès devant le tribunal de
westminster et après avoir épuisé les
voies de recours internes au royaume uni
si jamais comme c'est probable
la décision du tribunal de westminster
est défavorable à assange à ce moment là
les avocats d'assange pourront saisir la
cour des droits de l'homme parce
qu'effectivement c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup des ong il ya les médecins on
vient de vous
qui se sont manifestés des journalistes
également
néanmoins c'est un peu le gouvernement
comment l'expliquer alors pour les
gouvernements c'est tout à fait
explicables fait un sujet comme on l'a
dit dans votre reportage un sujet
extrêmement sensible politiquement
peu d'états ou de gouvernements veulent
ouvertement braver les états unis
d'amérique qui ont font une affaire
j'allais dire depuis des années et
s'acharne pour avoir l'extradition
d'assange donc pour eux c'est un combat
de longue haleine et face à cet
acharnement peu gouvernement peut-être
la corée du nord on ne sait pas vaut
prendre la défense de la change
au fond c'est une affaire d'espionnage
selon vous où davantage une affaire liée
à la liberté de la presse
pour moi c'est davantage une affaire de
liberté de la presse mais évidemment la
frontière n'est pas toujours très très
très ferme entre entre ces deux domaines
et il est vrai que la demande
d'extradition des états unis est fondée
sur le crime ou le délit d'espionnage
alors qu'à l'origine c'était un délit
d'informatique c'est-à-dire de
manipulation d'un ordinateur
juridiquement comment prouver qu'on n'a
pas forcément à faire une affaire
d'espionnage justement mais davantage à
une affaire liée de à la liberté de la
presse
alors là je compte beaucoup sur mes
confrères britanniques qui en général
sont excellents qui connaissent bien
aussi la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme pour mener un combat
qui à mon avis est justifié et pour
empêcher que julian assange un jour soit
extradé vers les états unis
pour conclure le
procès commence donc le 24 février
prochain il va être long vous l'avez dit
à quoi est-ce que vous serez
particulièrement attentifs moi je serai
très attentif à ce que les avocats
d'assange invoque à bon escient
la jurisprudence de la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme qui interdit très
fermement les peine perpétuelle c'est à
dire incompressibles il faut qu'à tout
moment il faut que le détenu qu'on avait
puisse avoir un minimum d'espoir d'une
libération anticipée et donc moi je suis
j'ai très confiance pour mes confrères
de ce point de vue là merci beaucoup
vincent berger d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris ancien expert
auprès du conseil de l'europe et anciens
juristes consultants de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme